all right
good
see you my boy
ah this sucks
help
oh wait wait wait wait i'm picking up an
echo
hell yeah i'm saved over here
who are you and do you know where i can
find the family jewel
oh i know the family jewel i'm bayless
the ship's navigator i'll prove it
here's coordinates for my ass now come
save it
another more
uh
through
oh
good
uh
felix are you nearby
almost there but i'm kind of in the
middle of something and that something
is a big [__] dinosaur heads up
kill it come on man you gotta kill it
oh
strike now peace
damn it was
is this your
default physical state
hey i don't i don't want to talk about
it why are you looking for the family
jewel
i hunt a vault key fragment and wayne
wright jacobs tells me there is one on
the ship
oh you're with wayne right okay all
right
[__]
the jewel appears to be in disrepair
yeah i had to make an emergency landing
after a disagreement between me and my
combat pilot genevieve
a mutiny then
sounds better than a messy breakup so
we'll just leave it at that the
emergency hatch over there is held shut
with hydraulic lines cut those and we're
in
now that i got you taking back the
jewels gonna be no problem
genevieve's locked it down tight but i
know all the back routes
pays to have a navigator on your side
[Music]
damn
you look
intact at least
felix you little cutie idiot why are you
here didn't i install you in a kid's toy
and toss you out with the trash
cram it genevieve i got a friend now
we're here for the key fragment i know
you got it in the security hole
oh sorry that's spoken for aurelius said
if i brought it back to her she'd buy me
a dreadnought so i'm gonna do that
not if we get it first we're coming for
that fragment
oh come on in what you gonna do navigate
me to death try to course up your own
ass
i can do more than navigate vault hunter
go through the medical bay
oh crap i navigated again stupid
shut up [__] you shoved me in a teddy
bear
go and meet them
that's messed
you have fighting you
oh yet
that's not how it works in the echo
shows
[Music]
it worked out nothing to worry about no
reason to be mad at me
hmm
well-tracked peace
medical staff only clearance required
man i have clearance i'm the navigator
error
entity baylex classified as an unlovable
idiot who never satisfied anyone
yeah i've heard that before
this is genevieve's doing i think i know
a way around it though fault hunter
knock this fool's head off
feel the bloodlust
ow
[Music]
oh man
oh it feels so good to move
around i have arms now
what's this do
navigated [__] ass
this way fault hunter we gotta get to
the security hole to find that key
fragment
balex your designation intrigues me
oh yeah yeah it stands for binary
automated legislation
all right my old man jacobs couldn't
decide whether he wanted to call me
barry or alex so he ended up calling me
baelix i know it's not the coolest
origin story
512 character alphanumeric designation
has no meaning but i have shortened it
to flag for the sake of time
well we all got off better than
genevieve that ain't even how numerals
work
[Music]
oh crap kill it
this is my purpose
ah
with
ugh
we're coming up on the security hole
it'll be right around ah crap i'm
navigating again you know what
you find it
[Music]
ah
you do me proud beast
there's the door to the security hole
and genevieve's barricaded it my met by
clearance won't do anything here great
oh security there's an adorable little
idiot criminal trying to break in please
pull him apart
slowly
i'm not adorable oh crap here they come
uh
that is your target
illegal use of radiation
you there how are your last breaths
killer so
we ain't getting through that door but i
know a side roof let's go
all right here i'll get the door
who here
i like you when you're angry
all and be reborn to the hunt
so
okay
yourself
right
illegal use of radiation
oh
hell yeah
[Music]
it's really beautiful
things you are forgotten
so many of them
that's the jabber said
[__] your target
[Music]
boy
oh
hmm
come back i've nearly got to sell over
oh crap
my body my beautiful body
foreign
a little help here don't step on the
chips
but mostly the manufactured thing
okay listen i got an idea on how to beat
genevieve now she's installed herself
into a maliwan met but there's a second
one in the shuttle bay if we get me into
that one genevieve won't be able to stop
us let's head through engineering
good job
so much
really terminated
be friendly